d'un dépôt de bilan
asus et des banques je comprends
pourquoi vous êtes venu à gibraltar et
peut-être trouvé une solution pour nous
donner un peu d'air j'ai rencontré un
douanier qui me fait une proposition
tu comptes parlant c'est tous les mecs
qui passent par ici tous les trafiquants
ce à quoi je ferai ça puisque j'ai gagné
10% mais tous convaincus par la houle à
elle passait bien a dit c'est pas notre
part ne s'est pas au pathos et des
crédits qui s'accumulent pas remboursé
c'est ça notre réalité c'est ça nous dit
désormais ils m'ont fait dans la drogue
monsieur duval ampleur convertir leurs
gros billets en armes de guerre j'étais
proposé pour une opération de convoyage
légal vous faites pour la publicité et
monsieur lui valent une grosse saisie de
drogue ça montre aux gens que les
douaniers seront au moins aussi
important qu'elle continue écoute moi ta
famille vous êtes souvent protection à m
que les choses soient claires
je peux dire
j'ai besoin de cet argent
monsieur de balle vous êtes un menteur
il vous avez peur j'ai peur je suis pas
content je suis pas un menteur
tu crois quoi tu te rends pas grand
frère c'est ça mais un peu tard personne
n'était là au moment où j'en avais
besoin d jamais venu
c'est l'un des plus gros
narcotrafiquants il est dangereux car je
comprends
j'ai plus confiance en toi ben imani de
confiance en personne
alors qu au trafic en cours je travaille
pour l'état moi je travaille pour les
douanes françaises
je trouve pour toi
ce que tu fais pas de signaux perd pas
confiance d'accord ouest une chose à
faire dit sol est finie